jean louis trintignant est ce que c'est
un problème de travailler pour sa femme
pas du tout au contraire ça plaisir ce
sont ces son premier film elle son
premier long métrage elle a créé des
primes pour la télévision et des courts
métrages longs métrages
est-ce que j'ai d'accéder de travailler
pour vale uniquement parce que c'est
vraiment vraiment parce que la cession
est intéressé non parce que c'est le
scénario m'intéressait non non je
l'aurais pris même si je n'avais pas
connu c'est vrai est-ce que tu n'es pas
du clown enfin je l'aide en tant que
comédien s'est tu n'es pas du tout en
dehors de sa fin est ce qu'après la
réalisation d'un homme et une femme
n'est pas eu d'autres procès peut-être
plus intéressant avec de très grands
réalisateurs sais mais ça ne m'intéresse
pas parce que j'aime bien car des
pipelines qu'on fait à la maison et
qu'on fait j'aime pas les grandes
productions seulement en huit heures
ici les mots
avec des moyens avec des grands films va
s'amoindrir
j'aime bien faire des petits films parce
qu'on participe davantage parce que
l'acteur a plus de plaisir à travailler
à être ou collaborateur d'un jeune
metteur en scène plutôt que de faire des
films avec des grandes villes et
villages est ce que c'est difficile de
vivre ici
ce scénario je vous connais depuis un an
et il ya tous travaillé pour moi c'est
surtout la bigne ce qui est tout à
l'heure je vous dire on a tous à portée
de main en connaît un peu parce que le
réputé parc alors nadine marquant
comment allez vous signez votre film
nadine vacants ou nadine trintignant
c'est pas comme ça viendra que si pointe
le problème des rapports qui veulent
exister dans un même film
un mari et sa femme est-ce que vous avez
des difficultés à diriger votre mari
jean louis trintignant non frères et ses
complices avec lui je le connais bien je
sais bien qu'à l'acteur river je sais
tout
j'aime twitter avec pourquoi le choix
des acteurs jean louis trintignant et
valérie lagrange est ce que j'avais
repris le duo the à nommer une femme
school a été volontairement enseignants
au contraire j'ai pris malaisie
pas du tout forcé les jeunes femmes les
forces avec en même temps une femme
jeune ou et quel site femmes c'est à
dire les jeunes vers la fin la d26 pas
la tête à tête non pauline comédienne a
vraiment une tête de femme sexy m'a
influencé eu aussi que justement n'a pas
fait de films récents
j'aurais pas pris une partenaire et que
tout un film avec jean louis mais moi ça
m'aurait enlevé les possibilités la fing
le tourner avec jean-louis l'appel une
seule sénat examine aussi pas mal avec
une scène vous c'est votre premier grand
frère est ce que jean louis trintignant
votre mari votre aise dans la
réalisation non dans la réalisation
absolument pas il m'a influencé au stade
de distribution valérie ça l'amusé
avec elle quand il est question par un
comédien je le laisse tomber la fiancée
pour lui parce que c'est qu'il connaît
très bien ça mais la réalisation du tout
mon amour en avant le titre de votre vie
c'est une fatigue production avec de
petits moyens